[Musique]
vous êtes dans le désert tout à coup
apparaît une sorte de tâche qui
ressemble à un étang mais c'est une
illusion un pur phénomène optique lié à
la déviation de faisceaux lumineux à
travers des couches d'air de température
différente
c'est un mirage bonjour je m'appelle
Nicolas riqueta et je vais vous montrer
que les grands classiques de la
littérature sont un peu comme les
mirages on croit qu'on sait ce qu'on
voit mais il ne s'agit que d'une image
qui est intimement dépendante du trajet
qu'elle a parcouru
la lumière du Mirage nous parvient
déformer à travers l'espace le sens du
classique nous parvient transformé à
travers le temps les classiques se
transforment à travers le temps ça on a
du mal à l'accepter parce que tout est
fait à l'école pour nous faire croire
que les grands auteurs ont pondu des
chefs qui nous sont livrés tout frais
sans que personne d'autre n'y est
touchées
il se trouve que c'est une question qui
m'intéresse tout particulièrement parce
que je fais une thèse en histoire de la
littérature pour mes recherches je vais
dans des archives un peu partout en
France et je compare des cahiers
d'élèves qui ont entre 15 et 17 ans au
18e et au 19e siècle
ce sont de vieux cahiers parfois il y a
des ratures parce que l'encre à bavé ou
des gribouilles d'ados qui s'ennuient
alors que la révolution est sur le point
d'éclater
mon travail c'est de regarder comment on
présente les oeuvres à l'école comment
on oriente la lecture des élèves par les
questions qu'on leur pose
ces questions elles distingue le
classique parmi tous les autres livres
ce dont on dit qu'ils ne sont pas de la
grande littérature
un livre c'est bien
mais un classique
c'est important
regardez cette métaphore
ce qui asthme vous avez vu cette rime
riche
et ce paraclositéone il n'aurait pas pu
l'écrire autrement ça y est on a planté
dans le crâne des adolescents l'idée que
les classiques sont figés immuables
immortel on contemple le mirage en
réalité ces livres sont édités puis
réédité avec des modifications ne
serait-ce que dans leur présentation
leur orthographe est modernisée ils sont
censurés simplifiés oubliés parfois
entièrement réécrit les classiques se
transforment à travers le temps
et les premiers à modifier les
classiques ce sont les auteurs eux-mêmes
prenons un exemple Jean Racine prenez en
compte les critiques qu'on lui adressait
pour changer des éléments de ces
tragédies d'une édition à l'autre il
changeait même le sens qu'il leur
donnait au fil de ses préfaces
vous lisez Andromaque de Jean Racine
c'est bien mais quel Andromaque celle de
1668 où l'Andromaque de 1674 vous
regarderez la prochaine fois c'est
indiqué au début du livre on peut aussi
penser à Montaigne qui est revenu à
plusieurs moments de sa vie sur ses
essais ce qui fait que ça a toujours été
un calvaire à éditer
mais la réécriture des classiques ne
s'arrête pas à leurs auteurs
l'histoire fait son travail
si vous avez vécu sous Napoléon vous
auriez par exemple pu avoir la chance de
lire des œuvres célèbres réécrites par
la censure celles et eux celles et ceux
parmi vous qui n'aiment pas trop lire
aura été ravi puisque à cette occasion
nombre de ces ouvrages ont été
drastiquement raccourcis et oui dès
qu'une pièce de théâtre même ancienne
parler un peu trop du retour d'un roi
hop on supprime à la scène
vous n'aimez pas les livres censurés pas
de problème
laissez-moi vous présenter les
classiques améliorés au même moment
toujours sous Napoléon on développe
l'idée selon laquelle le 17e siècle
constitue le summum du génie français on
va alors réécrire des pièces de cette
époque pour qu'elle correspondent à
cette idéale de perfection
Phèdre de Jean Racine ben par exemple
être corrigé à cette occasion pour
enlever les mots qui font un peu trop
vieillot
dans la même lancée des bonnes idées un
dramaturge nommé Jean-François cavaillat
de l'estandoux décide de remolériser les
pièces de Molière qui ne font pas assez
Molière à son goût
je vous rassure ces versions sont pas
celles que vous trouvez aujourd'hui dans
le commerce
mais si c'était que fou on peut être
effacé d'un coup de manche du tableau
noir de l'histoire littéraire certains
classiques ont connu des destins
incroyables qui ont participé à forger
l'image que l'on en a aujourd'hui
mettons qu'il me prenne l'envie là
maintenant de quitter la scène et de me
rendre dans la librairie la plus proche
pour acheter Les Fleurs du Mal de
Charles Baudelaire une pulsion plus
fréquente qu'on ne croit chez les
professeurs de lettres
bonjour Pierre libraire de la rue montée
vidéo à deux pas de la vénérable
Université Paris Dauphine pouvez-vous me
procurer les fleurs du mal de Charles
Baudelaire je vous prie bon bah je vous
parie mon poids en oeuvre complète de
Victor Hugo que la version qui me
donnera ne sera pas celle que le poète
avait initialement écrite
la première version des Fleurs du Mal
celle qui avait été patiemment forgée
dans l'esprit du génie et publié en 1857
contenait 100 poèmes pas un de plus elle
a dû être retirée des ventes suite à un
procès pour outrage à la morale publique
le recueil est censuré
pourtant il y croyait à son grand projet
politique Baudelaire mais il s'est
retrouvé le bec dans l'eau comme les
oiseaux qui peuplent le son oeuvre comme
son voyageur
qu'il décrit toujours déçu
le pauvre amoureux des pays chimiques
faut-il le mettre au fer le jeter à la
mer ce mateloivrogne inventeur
d'Amérique dont le mirage durant le
gouffre plus amer
c'est vert qui achètent presque l'un des
plus grands recueils de la littérature
française n’était initialement pas dans
Les Fleurs du Mal ils ont été rajoutés
après le procès furieux et désabusé par
le drame qui a brisé son œuvre
Baudelaire a en fait entièrement remanié
et republier l'ouvrage à plusieurs
reprises et une version encore
différente c'est imposée après sa mort
quand je demande les fleurs du mal au
séminion libraire de la rue montée vidéo
il devrait me répondre lesquels
les livres ne sont pas que des textes
qui filent de la main de l'auteur pour
s’arrimer à notre coeur ils ont une
histoire et cette histoire est en
quelque sorte co-autrice des grandes
œuvres
au fond parce qu'elle est à faire
d'édition la littérature est un art
collectif
et ça ne s'arrête pas là
nos petites histoires agissent tout
autant que la grande pour changer le
sens que l'on donne aux classiques
tandis que mes éléphants perce faisaient
dézinguer la trompe par des chevaliers
teutoniques je tendais l'oreille vers la
scène qui déroulait dans la cuisine
écoutez
tout se passe derrière une porte fermée
mon frère prend une grande inspiration
ma mère est attentive ce qui n'empêche
pas de continuer à s'activer sur ces
quiche lorraine j'entends la fourchette
qui claque contre un grand saladier en
métal le truc c'est Draper sur la
préparation un peu de noix de muscade
j'en sens encore l'odeur
et tout à coup
Blaise Pascal
le passé et le présent sont nos moyens
le seul avenir est notre fin
ainsi nous ne vivons jamais mais nous
espérons de vivre et nous disposons
toujours à être heureux il est
inévitable que nous ne le soyons jamais
des années plus tard je devais me dire
que les propos de Pascal faisaient
singulièrement écho aux pauvre amoureux
des pays chimiques décrits par
Baudelaire le philosophe et le poète ont
à deux siècles d'écart bien réussi à
croquer cette incapacité de l'homme à
rester en place dans le présent qui lui
est offert un peu plus haut dans son
poème le voyage que je visitais tout à
l'heure Baudelaire écrivait d'ailleurs
de sublimestroff qui leur aurait pu
emprunter à Pascal Le on y retrouve cet
art du paradoxe que sherissait le
penseur et cette même folie des hommes
qui se croit guidés par la raison
nous imitons horreur la toupie et la
boule dans leur Val c'est leur bon même
dans nos sommeil la curiosité nous
tourmente et nos rôles comme un ange
cruels qui fouette des soleils
singulière fortune qui toujours se
déplace et n'étant nulle part peut-être
n'importe où l'homme dont jamais
l'espérance hélas
trouver le repos court toujours comme un
fou
pour trouver le repos court toujours
comme un fou paradoxe folie des hommes
pour moi comme peut-être pour vous
maintenant Pascal est Baudelaire discute
à travers le temps nos vies nos lectures
donnent un sens nouveau au classique
bon à ce moment-là planter dans mon
écran couvert de canal d'éléphant en
Perse il se trouve que je me dépasse ses
réflexions déjà parce que je connaissais
pas les fleurs du mal mais aussi parce
que la citation avait un peu de mal à
sortir de la bouche de mon frère
le présent et le passé sont notre faim
non son homme moyen quand ma mère
patiente lui dit le texte exact je me
surprends à essayer de l'apprendre plus
vite que lui le passé le
présent
je sais pas pourquoi j'essaie
d'apprendre plus vite que lui
peut-être que je voudrais pouvoir me
glisser dans la cuisine pour lui
souffler discrètement la bonne réponse
peut-être que je voudrais pouvoir surgir
triomphalement pour déclamer la citation
avant lui pour l'emmerder
peut-être aussi que j'essaie d'apprendre
parce qu'elle est quelque chose de
mystérieux
elle recèle une sorte de sagesse qui ne
se laisse pas facilement élucider
nous ne vivons jamais mais nous espérons
de vivre
c'est beau cette tendance un peu surné
là nous espérons de vivre
et le constat radical limpide presque
trivial un paradoxe qui sonne en fait
comme une malédiction et nous disposons
toujours à être heureux
il est inévitable que nous ne le soyons
jamais
Blaise Pascal n'a jamais écrit Les
Pensées de Pascal telles qu'on les
connaît
on l'a retrouvé mort un 19 août il avait
39 ans il s'était épuisé à la tâche
on a ramassé chez lui tout un tas de
documents qui ont été tant bien que mal
assemblés
qu'on dise pas que j'ai rien écrit de
nouveau la disposition des matières est
nouvelle pensée 575 dans l'édition
Philippe sellier pour Pascal c'est
l'ordre de ses notes qui en faisait la
nouveauté qui ont donné le sens et c'est
bien là le problème aujourd'hui encore
les spécialistes se battent pour savoir
comment classer tout ça et pour cause
les feuilles retrouvées étaient bien
attachées en liasse comme de tout petits
chapitres mais pour déterminer l'ordre
de ces chapitres qui pour Pascal et sa
grande nouveauté bah là on est super
paumé et bien un fragment qui ressemble
à un sommaire un autre qui s'intitule le
commencement
mais dès qu'on y regarde de plus près
rien de colle vraiment et encore on a la
chance de tout avoir parce que pendant
un siècle la moitié était censurée
pourquoi je voulais tant connaître cette
citation
je crois que je voulais juste partager
quelque chose avec mon grand frère à un
moment de notre vie où on change tous
les deux beaucoup et la façon que j'ai
eu d'aborder ce texte par la suite était
profondément intimement lié au souvenir
premier de la récitation derrière la
porte
j'ai lu les pensées à travers mon frère
comme j'ai dû faire sur les conseils
d'une professeure qui nous l'avait
expliqué magistralement où les
misérables parce que j'avais adoré la
version Super pics ou géant en CM2
j'ai lu à travers et je crois que c'est
ce qui fait que la littérature est un
art collectif
on lit toujours à travers un conseil un
ordre une ambiance un regret
un espoir
à travers la porte d'une grande cuisine
qui s'appelle l'histoire
la littérature est un art collectif
parce qu'au fond
on lit toujours par quelqu'un d'autre
Blaise Pascal est mort d'épuisement un
jour de grande chaleur
c'était un 19 août
date de la naissance de mon frère
les livres comme les hommes ont une vie
qui les change
et les événements qui nous font
rencontrer ces vieillards plus ou moins
bavards
sont parfois aussi arbitraires qu'une
date d'anniversaire
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]